die kölner justiz die zuletzt fast ein
halbes jahr lang tanzte bandidos
den behörden auf der nase herum und
löste sich zwischenzeitlich sogar in
luft auf bis jetzt wir fassen ihnen das
versteckspiel des rockers noch mal
zusammen
jetzt ist vorbei mit der übeltäter rey
der rüpel rocker aiko ist gefasst nach
fünf monaten flucht geschnappt luft
geschnappt spielt und das obwohl du dich
liebe krieg doch immer für den
schlaueren gehalten hast aber alles auf
anfang im juni 2020 wird alkohol horst
der bandidos festgenommen
der grund eine schießerei mit den
befreundeten hells angels in der nähe
des kölner doms aber der protz rocker
hat glück wegen unerlaubten führens
einer schusswaffe wird er nur zu
zweieinhalb jahren haftstrafe verurteilt
und das sogar auch noch im offenen
vollzug
die haft tritt der 33-jährige aber nie
an erst musste angeblich sein haus in
der türkei verkaufen dann hatte er
corona und am ende zwickte auch noch der
rücken ein hexenschuss
der staatsanwaltschaft wird das zu recht
zu buhen und die erlässt deshalb
haftbefehl doch in köln barcode gar
nicht mehr der rüpel rocker einfach
abgetaucht spurlos knapp zwei monate
später wird er aber in der spanischen
urlaub statt marbella dingfest gemacht
und das bei einem abendlichen
spaziergang an der promenade tja pech
gehabt ausgerückt nach zweimonatiger
flucht ist der kölner rocker in marbella
festgenommen worden kurz antwort die
ließ nicht lange auf sich warten
[Musik]
hält die justiz und uns von bild zum
narren wie konnte das passieren
die spanische polizei ließ ihn mit einer
elektronischen fußfessel und
meldepflicht wieder frei wieder
verschwindet und wieder führt er die
behörden an der nase herum und dann vor
zwei wochen der durchbruch bei einer
großrazzia die taiko den behörden
zufällig als beifang ins netz die
beamten finden 11,5 tonnen
11,5 tonnen weißes gold auf einem dreier
großen schiffscontainer und nein es ist
kein mehl dass die polizei dort gefunden
hat die spur führt zu seinem belgischen
rocker kollegen und bandidos chef gerd
friese der zufällig auch immer wer wohnt
und raten sie mal wer sein nachbar ist
genau deutsche und belgische
spezialeinheiten stürmen die wohnanlagen
und bringen den rüpel rocker in die jva
remscheid es hat sich tatsächlich aus
gerockt mit dem trotz ist es jetzt erst
mal vorbei vielleicht darfst du lieber
tot aber wenigstens eine lilafarbene
couch mit in die neue zelle nehmen tja
wer zuletzt lacht der lacht halt immer
noch am besten
tja und zugeschaltet ist ja sehr bild
chefreporter frank schneider frank er
das klingt wie eine posse ist es aber
nicht
naja was heißt es ist keine post ist
folgendes gewesen er hat es halt einfach
clever angestellt hat die justiz nicht
nur in deutschland auch später in
spanien erst mal muss man ja mal sagen
die strafe die er bekommen hat extrem
milde man konnte ihn eben keine
tötungsabsicht unterstellen man konnte
auch nicht ausschließen hat in notwehr
gehandelt weil diese auseinandersetzung
mit den hells angels und hat er nur 200
jahre bekommen wegen unerlaubten
waffenbesitzes und er hat auch sogar
offenen vollzug bekommen dann könnt ihr
eigentlich denken der muss wirklich drei
bäume schlagen das ist so glimpflich
davongekommen aber er hat dann
entschlossen ich will auch nicht in den
offenen vollzug ich will auch nicht
nachts in der zelle schlafen und hat
dann eben immer dinge vorgeschoben habe
neben dem beitrag gehört erst war es
angeblich ein haus verkaufen was corona
dann war es ein hexenschuss
aber die atteste fehlt und dann haben
die behörden irgendwann gesagt uns
reicht's wir beantragen ein haftbefehl
das hat er natürlich mitbekommen und ist
dann abgetaucht noch mal wer da gab es
einen internationalen haftbefehl der
wurde auch dort vollstreckt nach zwei
monaten dann hieß es aber er darf gegen
meldeauflagen und eine fußfessel wieder
auf freien fuß und die deutschen
behörden sollen ihn abholen als die dann
kommen wollten war erneut abgetaucht und
dann kam es eben zu dieser großen razzia
und hatte er das große pech dass er in
der nachbarwohnung wohnte des dort
beschuldigten belgischen rockers und die
polizei natürlich das objekt observiert
vor dem zugriff und haben dann gesehen
wer geht denn da ein und aus in dieses
haus wer wohnt denn da auch noch den
suchen wir doch auch ja und so kam es
zum zugriff und jetzt ist er überführt
worden vor zwei tagen und sitzt in der
jva remscheid mit offenem vollzug ist
jetzt jedenfalls erst mal vorbei es hat
sich alles erst nach so zufalls treffern
an wie du schon beschrieben hast warum
glänzt die polizei da so gar nicht
naja was heißt die polizei grenzt nicht
erst mal ist es ja so dass der
haftantritt der hat die polizei nichts
mit zu tun der haftantritt da hat ja
auch keiner mit gerechnet bei 200 jahren
hoffnung vollzug ist es jetzt nicht
unbedingt eine strafe wofür man
abtauchen und sozusagen größeren ärger
riskiert und die spanischen behörden
auch gesagt na ja das ist halt
unerlaubter waffenbesitz das ist jetzt
nicht so ein schwerwiegendes delikt und
es sind nur hat zweieinhalb jahre vor
vollzug dafür sperren wir den jetzt hier
nicht länger ein außerdem hat ja auch
beteuert er lebt dort mit seiner familie
mit seinen drei kindern seiner frau und
er will einfach nur in seinem haus bei
seiner familie sein und er stellt sich
den deutschen behörden und das hat aber
eben nicht gemacht und daraus hat man
jetzt gelernt deshalb wie gesagt jetzt
ja jetzt eben nicht nur im offenen
sondern geschlossenen vollzug und wird
seine zweieinhalb jahre wahrscheinlich
dann auch wirklich bis zum letzten tag
verbüßen müssen er war chef der bandidos
in köln ist köln jetzt ein stück
sicherer
na ja ein stück weit sicherlich schon es
ist immer die frage ist wachsen ja in
diesen strukturen auch immer wieder
leute nach manchmal ist es auch so dass
solche festnahmen oder verhaftungen auch
eher zu auseinandersetzungen führen
wollen entsteht ein vakuum in der szene
andere wollen rein drängen andere wollen
führungspositionen andere wollen mehr
geld verdienen und dann gibt es auch
zusätzlichen ärger nun muss ich ja noch
mal vergegenwärtigen 2009 10 gab es in
köln auf den ringen einen regelrechten
rockerkrieg der damalige
polizeipräsident auch jetzt noch polizei
weisen uwe jakob sagte damals in einer
pressekonferenz das sei wie im wilden
westen da würde mit hochkarätigen waffen
herum geschossen und das ließe die
polizei nicht zu die polizei hatte das
auch massiv verstärkt hat auch massive
einsätze gefahren die situation hat sich
auch wirklich deutlich beruhigt
insgesamt hat sich die rockerszene ein
wenig beruhigt sie haben dass kunden
verbot sie können sich nicht mehr
martialisch zeigen aber in köln brodelt
ist immer man muss wissen in köln die
ringe waren lange in der hand von den
hells angels dann wurden sie schwächer
und dann trinke nebenbei kommt mit
seiner band ii tus dort hinein dass er
jetzt sitzt kann sein dass es erst mal
ruhe bringt in die szene die straßen
etwas sicherer macht aber diese
schießereien die wir vor zwei jahren
noch erlebt haben sind zum glück in der
jüngsten vergangenheit ausgeblieben wir
hatten allerdings einen fall innerhalb
der hells angels um möglicherweise auch
als ein straff auftrag auf einen rocker
geschossen wurde er wurde zum glück
verfehlt ist jetzt im unter
polizeischutz und in der szene pudel ist
immer es geht um sehr viel geld es geht
gar nicht mehr um dieses rocker da sein
wie früher die haben alle gar keine
motorräder teilweise gar keine
führerscheine für motorräder sondern es
geht einfach darum unter diesem
deckmantel des rocker da seins
kriminelle geschäfte zu führen und
möglichst viele illegale gewinne zu
machen